Who was the first person to ever have
the idea of traveling through time?
If I had to guess,
I'd say it was probably an early human
tens of thousands of years ago who
stubbed his toe or tripped or lit his
hair on fire and in searing pain had the
thought,
I wish I would have not done that in
this really limited way.
Time travel as an idea.
It's probably as old as regret,
which is to say as old as humanity
itself,
human beings have an instinctive sense
for cause and effect and a particular
skill for manipulating causes to get the
effects that they want and it makes
sense that are wandering minds would
look at the effects of what's already
happened in wonder what things might
look like if the causes had been
different somehow.
Which makes it kind of weird that time.
Travel as a device to tell stories is a
relatively recent phenomenon.
It might not seem that way since
traveling through time is such a staple
of modern science fiction and really the
modern imagination.
We've been so saturated with time
traveling novels and TV shows and movies
that the average person pretty much
understands all the basic concepts and
paradox,
but the time travel genre is only about
100 years old and change depending on
where you mark the beginning.
Many people see hg wells,
the time machine in 1895 as the start of
the genre.
Others look to mark Twain's,
a Connecticut Yankee in King Arthur's
court from a few years later.
Some even cite Charles Dickens' a
Christmas carol with it's ghost of
Christmas,
past and future from 1843.
The truth is you can't really pinpoint a
specific novel as the genesis of time
travel fiction because the genre doesn't
pop into existence out of nowhere,
like Cyborg from the future.
It grew slowly from the ashes of a genre
that no one really knows about anymore,
but to understand that there is one
specific book you can mention in more
ways than one.
Charles Darwin's on the origin of
species triggered a sea change in
science and culture after origin was
published in 1859.
The idea of evolution,
not necessarily the idea of natural
selection was adopted fast,
really fast,
just a decade later,
evolution was assumed at several top
universities and it filtered down into
the popular consciousness.
It colored the way people thought,
not just about biology,
but about sociology too.
If species we're getting fitter and
fitter,
better and better.
Why not societies?
It's in this period that a certain kind
of novel becomes really popular.
It's called the Utopian Romance and it
culminates in Edward Bellamy's 1888
book,
looking backward in Bellamy's book,
the hero Julian West falls into a deep
hypnotic sleep and wakes up 113 years
later in the year 2000.
The world is totally changed into a
socialist utopia.
Essentially Bellamy's version of the
perfect society evolved out of the
Society of his own day.
The book was a huge success.
The second novel in all of American
literature to sell over a million copies
like successful things do,
it exploded the genre,
resulting in dozens and dozens of
Utopian stories written along a very
similar structure and with evolution as
the guiding principle utopias,
we're no longer on a last island or a
different world.
They were in the future in his
extraordinary book on time travel
fiction,
David Wittenberg shows that overtime the
utopian romance became really
preoccupied with how its heroes got to
the future.
A lot of the time people fell asleep and
woke up years later.
Other times,
people's minds were sent forward and
were able to come back.
People traveled to the future in hot air
balloons by lightening storms,
even once with the use of a special
shampoo.
In fact,
when hg wells solves the problem with
the mechanical time machine,
he's doing it for the same reason as
everybody else to create a realistic
frame for his own Utopian story or in
this case,
his criticism and satire of that shot.
Eventually,
the Utopian craze fell under the weight
of its own propaganda.
Today barely anyone reads or writes that
kind of fiction and nobody knows the
name of the author or the book that sold
a million copies 100 years ago,
but as Utopian fiction collapsed,
it left us with a framing device that
grew into its own genre.
That's where,
or rather when time travel fiction as we
know it comes from in the following
decades,
the genre would be transformed by the
discoveries of Einstein.
It would use a popular understanding of
space time to probe the paradoxes of
causality that we've all become so
familiar with,
but is Wittenberg notes time.
Travel fiction is essentially the child
of narrative itself.
Examining the nature of causality is the
same thing as examining the nature of
story because that's what a story is
caused an effect.
It's white time travel.
Movies and books are obsessed with
rules.
They're like laboratories of
storytelling.
Just create a world,
establish its rules,
and to ask what's possible.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was sponsored by the new
youtube red original series,
lifeline.
It's the first,
the very first Saifai narrative series
that red has produced about a company
called lifeline that sends its agents
into the future to save clients that
they know are going to die.
It's a really great concept and
personally I'm super excited that red is
actually green lighting shows like this.
I hope the future brings more by
talented creators.
In this case,
Sam and Nico from corridor digital are
directing the entire series and I've
been a fan of theirs for a while.
You can watch the first episode for Free
Right now by clicking the link right
here,
or the first link in the description.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.